not a chance they're my friends but he
can jump up there and get we want to get
yes hey I didn't get to see him in a red
Sun when he was in front of that silver
ball and so that is that is bad you know
so it doesn't matter where they go after
what matters is what state of mind are
they're using to play with the ball see
this is just a replica
but was very easy to prevent ever going
to a level one or two everything you
touch I thought about just the patient
part of it repetition that's where
everything is revengefully whatever you
do is repetition you know thank so
because you have a dog that has it in
incredible willpower you have to bring
the here as well be stubborn unplanned
the difference here that the ears are
relaxed when the breathing is changing
so see the change right anyway for the
change you want me to try to do that
don't try to just do it and I help you
you can try thing creates a different
manner okay I'll do it
yeah just and if they do it wrong it's
not a problem it's just it's just if the
whole mentality that's good that's good
step she's still excited
so should I bring it to the ball down
not yet look at what I do show no no
you're doing fine
look at it look looky here yeah she's
just watching that's right that's the
best person the ball is right there just
wait now so all the shadow things is
obsession right because he doesn't have
activities where he can drain his energy
he has no choice just to follow things
that are more accessible to him
the thing is you give in to what he
likes yeah right there you let him touch
because he touched and you didn't
correct him and then he like there we go
correct them and then bring them redo it
okay
you know just yes exactly look at the
difference on the face yeah well because
he passed by you like I got it yeah he's
yeah you know I mean you just brought
him here but psychologically didn't get
the whole point yeah and he thinks he
got away with it he did yeah and he
didn't think right he just see that
little lip right there steak that's just
dominance that's not aggression has AI
has a little flavoring yeah